buenas noches la demanda sostiene que el
congreso de perú hizo uso indebido de
sus atribuciones constitucionales para
declarar la vacancia presidencial por
incapacidad moral al presidente de
martín vizcarra se señala que esto
afecta la capacidad del mandatario para
gobernar y se le solicita al tribunal
constitucional que en ese sentido
declare la nulidad de todo lo actuado
por el parlamento el presidente de
vizcarra han denunciado que sufre de una
conspiración por eso es que su gobierno
se encuentra listo para solicitar la
carta democrática ante la organización
de los estados americanos este es un
mecanismo interamericano para la defensa
de los sistemas democráticos pero en ese
sentido no descarta solicitar a la oea
el envío de una misión a este país hoy
francisco y que reacciones han generado
el mensaje del presidente martín
vizcarra
algunos líderes políticos se han
pronunciado en contra de la aplicación
de la vacancia presidencial ellos le
piden a la fiscalía que efectúe una
investigación es activa y que el
mandatario sea procesado cuando culmine
su mandato por su parte algunos
legisladores sostienen que los audios se
mostrarían posibles manejos ocultos del
presidente de vizcarra y que éste tiene
que presentarse al parlamento pero ellos
sospechan que el mandatario no acudirá
el próximo viernes 18